mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
suppose
x plus the square root of one plus x
squared multiplied by y plus the square
root of one plus y squared is equal to
one
what is the value of the quantity x plus
y squared equal to
x and y are real numbers
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we will solve this equation by writing
an expression for y in terms of x
to get started suppose u is equal to x
plus the square root of 1 plus x squared
we will substitute that in
we will then divide both sides by u
and then subtract y from both sides of
the equation
we will then square both sides of the
equation
the left hand side becomes one plus y
squared
we will then square the right hand side
of the equation we'll substitute that in
we can now cancel out the y squared
terms on both sides
we now have a linear equation in terms
of y
let's go ahead and solve for y
we'll multiply both sides by u and then
we'll distribute the u
we can then divide both sides by 2 and
we have an equation for y in terms of u
let's simplify this expression
u is equal to x plus the square root of
1 plus x squared
what's its reciprocal equal to
we take its reciprocal and we can do a
classic trick we'll multiply the
numerator and denominator by the
conjugate
what this will do is it will make a
difference of squares in the denominator
this will simplify matters tremendously
now from here we can cancel out the x
squared terms in the denominator and
we're left with negative 1. therefore 1
over u is equal to the following
negative x plus the square root of 1
plus x squared
we can then substitute that in for what
we've solved for y
we then take 1 over u minus u
and then we simplify this
notice that the radical terms will
cancel out and we are left with just
negative 2x
thus y is equal to negative x
therefore we can solve the question
x plus y will be equal to x minus x
which is equal to 0 and therefore this
evaluates to be 0 and that's our answer
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you